a killing in Georgia has Americans at
each other's throats on race guns and
criminal justice
but while the left gins up a fake race
narrative and riles everybody up over a
very sad local story a major national
political scandal implicating the
highest levels of the Obama
administration goes uncovered how
convenient is that
then CBS gets caught lying about
coronavirus NBC gets caught lying about
attorney general bill bar and a reopened
gorge it disproves the co vid prophets
of gloom and doom all that more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
what did barack obama know and when did
he know it
that is the question on my mind today
it's the question i want to know what
you think about in the comments section
Michael Flynn FBI spying what did Barack
Obama know we'll get into some of the
evidence that's been dribbling out on
this because the mainstream media don't
want to cover it this is the big point
ok the mainstream media push fake news
in two different ways the first way
we're very familiar with they spin the
stories they make up some of the
reporting they exaggerate other parts of
the reporting right that's the first
part is how they report the stories but
the second part of how the Left pushes
fake news is actually more important
than that and that is how they select
the stories that they're going to cover
so it's not even in how they report it
it's in the very fact that they are
reporting some stories and that they are
not reporting other stories case in
point
great example of this is a very sad
local story the killing of Ahmad our
burry is the big story that blew up over
the weekend
it's got everybody at everybody's
throats and I think pretty much
everybody is missing the point at least
as a matter of national political
perspective what do we know about the
Ahmad Arbor eating two white guys shot
and killed a black guy named Ahmad our
burry the guys were tailing our burry in
a car this is in Georgia the two guys
had their guns out right so they they
were brandishing weapons are burry knew
that they had weapons there was a tussle
for one of the guns and our burry ended
up dead and we know all of this because
one guy a third guy filmed it for some
reason actually that does sort of play a
role in how we think about the case but
that's pretty much all that we know
about it right then predictably
left-wingers pushed this narrative that
this was a modern day lynching that
Ahmad was out minding his own business
out for a jog and these two crypto
Klansmen came up and lynched him then
some right-wingers pointed out that are
buried an arrest record that he had been
poking around a house that was an open
construction site in the neighborhood
and all of which I guess you know tells
us something about the left-wing
narrative doesn't really tell us much
about the case itself though right just
because a guy has an arrest record
just because he's poking around a house
that's under construction in the
neighborhood that doesn't justify
killing him doesn't no I don't think any
of us would say that
so then three questions about the
incident itself was it murder possibly
it was possibly murder but I don't know
that they're gonna get very far the
prosecutors if they push this idea that
it's murder because if it was just
murder if these two guys were out there
trying to snipe down a black man going
for a job they probably would have
killed him sooner wouldn't they they
they had the open shot they were
trailing him but they waited until he
grabbed for a weapon and then there's
this tussle that happens off-camera and
then he dies
is that going to stick as a murder
charge possibly but it's a tougher case
to make also if it was murder they
probably wouldn't have filmed it right
that doesn't make a lot of sense you
don't want to you don't want to film
yourself committing a crime on camera
was it manslaughter that seems more
likely you know these these guys were
out they were being vigilantes they were
following this guy who they suspected of
committing a non-violent crime and so
they didn't actually want to shoot him
but then you know Barberie feels like
he's pinned into a corner so he grabs
the gun reasonable thing to do and then
there's this tussle and you know somehow
Barberie ends up dead that seems far
more likely to me in terms of something
that's gonna stick for a prosecutor I
guess the third option is was it
justified this seems the least likely by
far to me you know if the crime is being
accused of his nonviolent and we don't
even know if our burry committed a
non-violent crime then that wouldn't
justify killing right nobody nobody
would suggest that probably people think
that these two guys were overstepping
they should have waited for the police
to get there so probably that's not
going to work okay from a national
political perspective
none of this
is the primary question I think most of
the discussion of the Arbor II killing
ends there was it murder was it
manslaughter was it justified he had an
arrest record none of that is the point
okay this I actually don't really want
to talk about the Arbor EK s-- I think
the Arbor ek siz a local very sad local
story I want to talk about the fact that
we're talking about the Arbor e case why
are we talking about this there were 53
homicides in the United States every
single day why this one why did this one
blow up is the big news story of the
weekend it's because it supports a
left-wing race narrative LeBron James is
the king of this LeBron tweets out we're
literally hunted every day every time we
step foot outside the comfort of our
homes can't even go for a damn jog man
like WTF man are you kidding me with
like seven exclamation points and
question marks no man for real are you
kidding me five exclamation points
I'm sorry Ahmad rest in paradise and my
prayers and blessings sent to the
heavens above to your family then it's a
prayer hand then it's a black power hand
then it's a red heart
hashtag stay woke hashtag profiled
because we are simply black than to
cryin faces that's not true what he
tweeted out is not true LeBron James is
not hunted down every time he leaves his
home the statistics are clear there is
no epidemic of racist White's hunting
down innocent black guys in the United
States it doesn't happen you can look at
the statistics it's not true on top of
that on this specific case we know of
very few people how many people could
you imagine in this country would
support the unjust killing of a man very
few people
the reason stories like this get
attention is because they are
exceedingly rare so what's the takeaway
here the takeaway is this is a very sad
local story that is made into a national
story to push a left-wing
race narrative and we should not fall
into the trap of encouraging that I
almost wasn't even going to talk about
this because I don't want to encourage
the left making a spectacle out of these
sad local stories to push a narrative
but I think it's important because
you've got to be aware when the left
does it every time the left is pushing
some story like this a story that is
obviously very emotional very sad very
dramatic but again local not indicative
of broader trends not relevant to
questions of national politics or
international politics every time
they're doing that it's because they
don't want you to be looking at another
story and that has never been truer than
this one there is serious bias going on
there's a big cover-up going on
we'll get to what in one second first
though I have got to thank our friends
over at Bambi I've got to thank all of
our sponsors we really appreciate them
sticking with us in these difficult
times and in a time of economic
uncertainty it is more important than
ever to have a good HR department when
running a business HR issues can kill
you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations
especially now that the regs are
changing like every five minutes and HR
Manager salaries are not cheap you know
the average HR manager in the United
States makes 70 grand a year
Bambi's spelled BA MBE e was created
specifically for small businesses you
can get a dedicated HR manager craft HR
policy maintain your compliance how much
how much would you pay for that about
$99 a month I know it seems unbelievable
but it's it's terrific with Bambi you're
dedicated HR manager is available by
phone email or real-time chat from
unmooring to terminations they customize
your policies to fit your business go to
Bambi dot-com slash Michael right now to
schedule your free HR audit that's Bambi
comm slash Michael BAM to the B EE comm
slash Michael mi CH AE L go check it out
sad is the local story is it has no
significance to national politics
broader trends left-wing race hustlers
are going to tell you that it does but
you can look at the statistics say
that's a good thing that it doesn't have
a relevance to broader trends right to
national politics meanwhile though there
is another news story that has major
significance for national politics and
that one at the mainstream media don't
want to cover that is the exoneration of
Mike Flynn the national security adviser
who was brought in it was the first NSA
under Trump and the FBI set him up
they tried not just to entrap him which
they they did but they tried explicitly
to get him fired
there was a major political component to
all of this the media are working
overtime to bury and rewrite this story
so from the moment that Mike Flynn was
fired what we heard uniformly from the
mainstream media they must have all
gotten the exact same talking point
sheet we were told that it was a
conspiracy theory that they went after
Flynn look Flynn was a dirty guy he had
dirty dealings with Russia was a good
thing that they got him out and any
suggestion that the FBI entrapped Flynn
was a wild conspiracy theory president
Trump and his top aides have been
routinely ignoring the truth and pushing
phony conspiracies here the president it
seems to be saying that this was a case
of entrapment that Michael Flynn was
essentially pressured into lying what is
your response
I think that's hogwash you know there
are all kinds of conspiracy theories
about how he was entrapped the FBI
agents didn't do anything wrong here so
I think that's important because there
are a lot of sort of conspiracy theories
they all work together and you know the
Fox News people in the White House fuel
these sort of rumors do they send these
around with fax machines they come up
with these conspiracy theories and they
send it around on fax machines they
should just knock it off and realize
that their ridiculous conspiracy
theories are going to be knocked down
stop stop with the conspiracy theories
so I think that loud sound you heard at
about 12:30 Eastern was the sound of
10,000 conspiracy theories by the Trump
defenders exploding the sound you hear
is a million conspiracy theories
exploding I could call them the trumpets
all over the country their heads were
blown up
here's another conspiracy theory that
has been blown to bits another
conspiracy theory blown to bits that
supercut goes on for I think another 40
seconds of the same exact conspiracy
theory conspiracy theory conspiracy
theory and in a way they're right the
idea that that Mike Flynn was set up by
the FBI was a conspiracy theory trouble
is every so often conspiracy theories
are true because there are conspiracies
and what happened to Mike Flynn was a
conspiracy we now know it we saw the
notes from the FBI they said what is the
goal here why are we questioning Flynn
is it to get the truth is it to catch
him in a lie or is it to get him fired
and he looked Flynn is not the only one
they went after we know that the FBI and
the DOJ and what we what we were called
a deep state of bureaucrats in the Obama
administration were spying on the Trump
campaign they were trying to undermine
the Trump campaign and then once Trump
was elected they tried to undermine the
administration in the case of Flynn
successfully now we know that the guy
was exonerated the DOJ is dropping the
case into Flynn entirely right total
exoneration a complete up ending of it
it was a conspiracy and the media were
part of that conspiracy against they
were covering up what was going on at
the time that Flynn was fired and
they're covering it up now okay they're
not running this they want to run
sensationalized stories to get people
ginned up emotionally about topics that
they can control topics that fit their
narrative not the other narrative that
Obama his administration was corrupt
he's a thoroughly corrupt Chicago
politician and by the way this scandal
might go all the way to the top of that
corrupt administration so they were
spreading lies and fake news then now
now that Flynn is exonerated the media
are still trying to cover it up Chuck
Todd I've got to play you this clip
Chuck Todd on NBC just aired a clip of
Bill Barr the Attorney
talking about this topic and he cut it
in such a way that bill Barr seems like
he was saying the opposite of what he
was actually saying and Chuck Todd is
not a stupid man the people at NBC are
actually not stupid people they know
exactly what they're doing and they are
trying to tell you the opposite of the
true news we'll get to that in a second
first I got to thank our friends over at
zip recruiter you know a lot of people
are looking for work right now friends
of mine are looking for work right now
relatives of mine are looking for work
they should make their job search as
efficient as possible sip recruiters
focus has not changed they are still
doing what they've done from the
beginning that is helping people who
need jobs find work and helping run
businesses find the right people for
their open roles so if you're looking
for a job right now know that zip
recruiter is working with you to find
the right job faster you know chaos
breeds opportunity doesn't always feel
like that but it does and superc Rooter
is there dedicated to helping you get
hired whether you're looking for jobs
and caretaking or food delivery and
goods or building medical facilities
supplying protective equipment right the
list goes on and on sip recruiters app
will send you up-to-date job openings so
you can be one of the first to apply by
connecting people who need jobs and
companies that need people zip
recruiters working with all of us so
that we can keep moving forward it's
very important right now times like this
for companies to come on together so
let's work together
zip recruiter dot-com slash work
together go check it out right now Chuck
Todd on NBC plays a clip of Bill Bar
talking about the Flint exoneration
listen to the clip listen to Chuck
Todd's reaction you brought a bill bar
peggy noonan i want you to listen to
this bill bar answer to a question about
what will history say about this where
do you hear this answer take a listen
when history looks back on this decision
how do you think it will be written well
history is written by the winners host
largely depends on
who's writing the history I was struck
PEGI by the cynicism of the answer it's
a correct answer but he's the Attorney
General he didn't make the case that he
was upholding the rule of law
he was almost admitting that yeah this
is a this is a political job if you only
saw the clip of bill Barr that Chuck
Todd played you would agree with that
right you know the way they cut it is
Bill Barr there well you know history is
written by the winners that's so it's
almost as though history isn't objective
it's just a matter of pure power and
we're gonna win because we're corrupt
that's the that's the implication of the
clip that Chuck Todd sang and then Chuck
Todd
right on cue he's pretty good actor that
guy he responds he says I'm floored
peggy noonan by the cynicism Oh
me I thought government was so much more
honest and straightforward than this but
I'm floored by the cynicism I'm floored
by the cynicism of Chuck Todd because
that guy deceptively edited that video
clip that's a phrase that is truly
abused in our culture but if it ever
applies it applies to what Chuck Todd
just did because he cut that clip out of
context he cut it before bill Barr makes
the argument that Chuck Todd says he
doesn't make take a listen to the whole
clip when history looks back on this
decision how do you think it will be
written well history is written by the
winners so it's largely depends on who's
writing the history but I think a fair
history would say it was it was a good
decision because it it upheld the rule
of law it helped it it upheld the
standards of the Department of Justice
and it undead what was it an injustice
this is the point Chuck Todd was trying
to pretend Bill Maher didn't make us
look this was a good decision
this decision upheld the rule of law
this decision upheld the standards of
the Department of Justice unlike what we
saw happening in the previous
administration we are actually going to
uphold standards of justice what about
that first part that Bill Barr was
joking about that Chuck Todd tried to
pretend was the whole clip the first
part was Bill Barr joking about exactly
what Chuck Todd was doing to him right
what bill bars joking about here is not
that he's gonna be the winner and he's
gonna write the history and he's gonna
write out all of the sins of the Trump
administration to make it look good bill
burr is joking about the fact that the
news media in particular in this country
don't give conservatives a fair shake
and therefore when history is written
when Hollywood rewrites histories which
they do all the time they're doing it
right now in a few notable cases then
they make conservatives look really bad
and they make liberals look really good
when many academic historians who lean
left-right histories they make the
conservatives look really bad they make
the liberals look really good he's
basically saying look we did this we
uncovered this we pursue justice we're
probably not going to get credit for it
because history is written by the
winners and the left tends to win in the
United States but regardless of how it's
written we did the right thing these
were the standards of justice Chuck Todd
exactly flips that that's what the media
do all the time and the reason they care
about this the reason they care about
what is a at this point what three and a
half year old issue the firing of Mike
Flynn the reason they care about Bill
Barr this you know veteran DC lawyer and
attorney general he's already served in
the role before the reason they care
about all of this is is because it
touches Obama it touches their golden
child Barak Obama no drama
Obama scandal-free Obama I mean forget
about fast and furious forget about the
IRS targeting Obama's political
opponents forget about this forget about
that forget about the spying and forget
about all of it right no scandals at all
they want to make his legacy look
pristine and it implicates a lot of
people now how do we know it implicates
a lot of people those of us who have
been suggesting for some time now that
perhaps the Obama administration knew
more than they're letting on about the
spying in to Donald Trump about the
undermining of the Trump administration
those of us who've been suggesting maybe
this goes a little bit higher in the
administration then people were letting
on we've been called conspiracy
theorists well as we just saw maybe the
biggest conspiracy theory of the last
three years turns out to have
true not because conspiracy theories are
true but because conspiracies
occasionally happened it looks like
we're looking at one Mike Flynn's lawyer
Sydney Powell went on Maria Bartiromo
show just a few days ago and talked
about the new evidence that is emerging
with the firing who made the call who
did it when who knew about spying where
these meetings took place and even if
some of them took place in the Oval
Office here's what Sydney Powell had to
say well the day before Comey had found
an McCabe had found the transcripts of
Flynn's call with kiss lyac and he
briefed clapper on it immediately
clapper then immediately went and
briefed President Obama on it then they
have the oval office meeting on the
fifth Comey admits in his testimony that
the FBI are the people that unmasked
general Flynn our people whatever that
means and at the meeting on the fifth
Sally Yates was stunned because Obama
mentions to her out of the blue about
the call and the transcript of the call
so you think this goes all the way up to
the top to President Obama absolutely
who's gonna be charged I have no idea
that's up to John Durham and Attorney
General senior now listen to that at the
end right and that nothing new that that
you and I haven't known for some time
now right that this involves a lot of
senior people it might go all the way up
to the top we know that Barack Obama was
very involved in these minut political
decisions he would brag about it right
he would always go out there and say I'm
a better political director than my
political director Obama kept a very
tight watch on these things so we knew
all that when Maria asks who's going to
be charged and could we see this go all
the way to the top Sydney Powell says
well you'd have to ask John Durham and
now this brings on the other side that
the mainstream media are now covering
there's a criminal investigation going
on right now there's an investigation of
the investigation you remember we've had
three years or whatever was two and a
half years of Russia gate
and the Muller investigation and all
those poor liberals were wearing shirts
that said it's Muller time we're gonna
take out Trump because he's colluding
with Russia he's actually a Manchurian
Candidate for Vladimir Putin you know
Donald Trump the guy we've all known for
40 years the famous TV show host and
yeah he's actually secretly a Russian
spy or something it was always a dumb
argument and then you know Muller
completed his investigation they didn't
get anything on Trump after that the
Attorney General appointed another guy a
US Attorney John Durham to start looking
into all the issues that surrounded that
Muller investigation that that second
investigation has been going on for some
time now it's directly related to the
events that we're talking about here if
you think that the exoneration of Mike
Flynn was the last we've heard on this
topic you are very mistaken we are
headed for some insane political times
and I know because it seems like we're
already living in very insane political
times there's a reason you haven't heard
about these stories on the mainstream
media there's a reason that the
mainstream media are desperate to push
any other story that they possibly can
especially these cynical divisive
stories these local stories that they
can make into national divisive
political issues the reason is they want
to distract you you should not allow
yourself to be distracted because for
those of us who are looking at the real
story right now it looks like the
characters implicated up to and
including Barack Obama are getting real
real nervous Obama came out swinging
against President Trump over the weekend
in a leaked phone call things are
getting very intense between these two
gentlemen in between the two political
sides of our country Trump came back
swinging against him major stories and
there's another story the mainstream
media are trying to cover up that
relates to exactly what we're living
through right now in this lockdown we'll
get to that but first I've got to thank
our friends over at LifeLock you know
there are a lot of internet scammers out
there all right and sometimes they get
you you know they get you on a fishing
expedition you put your password in
where you shouldn't put your password it
happens to the best of us it even I
ashamed to admit happens to me in a
recent study researchers revealed a
substantial rise in the number of cyber
attacks performed by websites posing as
Netflix especially these days that's
kind of nuts right scammers are focusing
more attention on people streaming
content during this stay at home era
nobody ever accused these criminals are
being dumb ok they're pretty sharp guys
and hackers are shifting their resources
away from targeting businesses and tort
activities that can reach us directly in
our homes on average over 2,600
coronavirus related cyber attacks occur
each day good thing there's LifeLock
which is a leader in identity theft
protection detects a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number for sale on the dark web
for instance no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions and all businesses but life
lock can see threats that you might miss
on your own if you're just monitoring
your credit join now save up to 25% off
your first year go to life lock dot-com
/ null scanner wles that's life lock
calm / Knolls for 25% off go do it right
now lifelike calm / knowles we've got a
lot more to get to a lot of it going up
to Barack Obama you can hear the man's
own words you know every until I hear
Barack Obama again I always forget what
a drag his presidency was what a
terrible president he was and then I'm
reminded of that well dark days may be
ahead for Barack Obama because he got a
pass from the mainstream media for a
long time but now it looks as though
some consequences are coming down the
pike then Georgia is looks like its
reopening and you haven't heard a whole
lot about that I wonder why we'll get to
why a lot more fake news we'll get to
that in a second but first I want to
take a moment to thank you and I want to
tell you about Daily wires newest most
exclusive membership tear the all-access
insider the all-access Insider
membership tear is our premier level of
membership what do you get you know what
you get you get the ad free website you
get the live Q&A discussions you get
more of the ben shapiro show you get a
leftist here's tumblr that's great
that's very important obviously these
days when we're gonna see the flynn
exoneration fill it up half way then the
durham investigation it's going
go over the top if you're in an
all-access insider tier though you also
get to participate in the all-access
live each night at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m.
Pacific
and you know who's hosting tonight Ben
so head on over to Daly wire.com slash
subscribe join the all-access club with
a new membership or an upgrade and get
10% off with coupon code Noll scanner
wles that's nearly wire comm slash
subscribe see you there
coupon code Knowles and you will get 10%
off
they're turning up the heat on Barack
Obama and you can see that the former
president is sweating he came out
swinging against President Trump over
the weekend in a leaked phone call that
he was having with his supporters
talking specifically about the Flint
exoneration the news over the last 24
hours
I think has been somewhat downplayed
about the Justice Department dropping
charges against Michael Flint and the
fact that there is no precedent then
anybody can find for someone who's been
charged with perjury just getting off
scot-free that's the kind of stuff where
you you begin to get worried that basic
not just institutional norms but our
basic understanding of rule of law is is
is is it risk so what he's saying is not
true for a few reasons
he's starting to get worried obviously
but he says there's no precedent for
someone who's been charged with perjury
to get off scot-free I wonder if Barack
Obama's ever heard of a guy named Bill
Clinton
excuse me mr. Obama have you ever heard
about your Democratic predecessor Bill
Clinton because I'm pretty sure he
perjured himself and I'm pretty sure he
got off scot-free for it he's trying to
focus on this question of lying Mike
Flynn lied and he's getting off
scot-free it's never happened before
he was entrapped by your goons okay if
you think there's no precedent for Mike
Flynn to get entrapped than to make a
slight mistake
than to have the FBI used that to try to
get him fired their words not mine is
there any precedent for a sitting US
president weaponizing his law
enforcement arms to undermine in
becoming presidential administration is
there any precedent for that I don't
think so
I think there is precedent for guys
being entrapped by the FBI I don't think
there's precedent for you
weaponizing your administration your
deep state your law enforcement arms to
undercut a political opponent and your
successor in the White House
that's what there's no precedent for
it's why we're in uncharted territory in
this case it's why we don't know what's
going to happen when we ask what did
Barack Obama know and when did he know
it the implication is that this could
this could involve Barack Obama in some
pretty dark stuff what do we do with
that we don't want to start throwing
former presidents in jail but we do want
people to be held accountable for
abusing their power which it certainly
would appear that senior Obama
administration officials did president
Trump responded to Obama's attacks on
him he just tweeted out one word Obama
gate and by the way I checked this
morning I think it was training at two
point six million tweets or something
like that and then you look and Twitter
tries to reduce the number of tweets so
then two hours later you look and it
says 2.1 million tweets you say hold on
the way there are fewer tweets now about
it than there were 12 hours ago Trump
wasn't happy to leave it at the one
tweet he was asked about what's going
what was going on in the Obama
administration he was asked about Mike
Flynn and he used the phrase
human scum to describe those top Obama
officials we get your reaction to some
breaking news the Justice Department has
decided to dismiss okay against Michael
anywhere that I didn't know that was
happening at this moment I felt it was
going to happen just by watching and
seeing like everybody else does he was
an innocent man he is a great gentleman
he was targeted by the Obama
administration and he was targeted in
order to try and take down a president
and what they've done is a disgrace and
I hope a big price is going to be paid
and I hope a lot of people are going to
pay a big price because they're
dishonest crooked people they're scum
and I say it a lot they're scum they're
human scum this should never have
happened in this country a duly elected
president and they went after him by
going after fine people and it's a
disgrace the Obama administration
Justice Department was a disgrace and
they got caught they got caught very
dishonest people but much more than two
sides treason it's treason that's a big
word treason is a big word and it has
serious consequences for how this sort
of thing will be prosecuted that's the
claim coming from President Trump and I
know that he's kind of loose with his
words sometime I don't think he's being
loose here I think this has been the
central issue of his administration the
this the central problem of his
administration is that that the left in
this country and his predecessor has
never accepted the Donald Trump been
elected and they've been trying to
undermine him the whole way and now it's
president Trump's turn to investigate
the investigators and it's probably not
going to turn out very well for them the
Flynn story is not the only national
political story that the left is trying
to cover up right now another one is
Georgia you remember at Georgia opened
up lifted the lockdown and we were told
they were gonna be deaths all on the
streets and it was going to be terrible
and and it'll prove that we need to stay
lockdown forever it's kind of weird that
we haven't heard about Georgia right you
would expect they promised us we're
gonna hear about Georgio it except they
haven't covered it cuz Georgia's doing
just fine
the Republican governor of Georgia Brian
Kemp celebrated the state's lowest
number of hospitalized coronavirus
patients on Saturday he also
liberated the fewest number of
coronavirus patients on ventilators on
Saturday that was 15 days after he
started to reopen his state why does
that matter well it matters because the
respiratory symptoms of coronavirus
typically start to appear that five or
six days after exposure it could be as
early as two days after exposure but the
longest it could be is 14 days after
exposure so they reopened the state and
things are doing fine and so what the
left isn't gonna grapple with that these
are the stories that matter right when
we're talking about our government the
absolutely rank corruption that was
going on in the Obama administration
that bled over into Trump as a tax on
Trump that's probably the biggest story
and then when we talk about our national
political situation right now the
lockdown is the biggest story it's a
question we have to say what do we do
about this are we going to remain locked
down forever shut down the global
economy keep 40 million people out of
work 50 million people out of work
let unemployment go past 20 percent
maybe the 30 percent maybe more all
right that's the question any evidence
that supports the left's desire to
remain locked down at least through the
2020 election is going to be pushed any
evidence that contradicts that narrative
is going to be suppressed and that's
what's going on in Georgia and we should
all tweet about it we should all post on
Facebook about it we should shout it
from the rooftops look at Georgia
Georgia is doing relatively very well
compared to other states that have
remained locked down that are not doing
as well okay I'm not saying that the
coronavirus issue is simple
I'm not saying lift all lockdowns right
now immediately and everything's going
to be fine don't misunderstand me but
what I am saying is look at all of the
evidence don't just look at the evidence
that the left wants you to look at the
most important media tool that the left
has for pushing fake news is this story
selection okay you see it again and
again sometimes though let's not let's
not go too much in that direction let's
not forget that sometimes one of the
tools that used to push fake news is
just to lie just to outright lie James
O'Keefe a project very to us showed us
this last week James O'Keefe showed that
CBS News
faked a segment about coronavirus
patients yet NBC News faked a segment
about Mike Flynn and now you have CBS
News faking they staged a line of car is
waiting to get treatment and tests for
coronavirus it wasn't real the people in
the cars were essentially actors they
were employees of the pharmacy or
employees of the news and that we're
posing as coronavirus patients here's
James O'Keefe you're telling me you're a
hundred percent certain that CBS News
CBS News Corporation national staged a
fake event they faked the news they
faked the reality and broadcasted that
to all of their audience last Friday on
CBS this morning that's me
apparently the news crew wanted more
people in the swathe at all they just
wanted it to look busy I mean it goes on
and on James O'Keefe talks to a lot of
people here it seems pretty clear they
will just lie to you you have to be on
guard for that too and so that's the
more obvious way that they they push
their narrative but they do that as well
the most important accomplishment of the
Trump administration so far has not been
on immigration it's not been on any one
political issue hasn't been the taxes it
has been destroying the credibility of
the media this is priority number one
because the media are the ones who craft
the whole way that we think and talk
about politics in this country from very
sad local stories all the way up to
national lock downs we got some good
news over the past couple of weeks which
is that President Trump's a new White
House press secretary Kayla Mack Kaylee
mackaninee is basically just as good at
it as Donald Trump is no one's quite as
good at smacking down the presses Trump
is but she is really talented at it she
held a press briefing she was asked
about a prior comment she'd made at some
point on Fox News and she was prepared
first of all ready for the question and
she flawlessly smacked these reporters
down daily in a previous life before you
were press secretary work
and he made a comment I believe on Fox
in which you said President Trump will
not allow the coronavirus to come to
this country given what has happened
since then obviously would you like to
take that back so this is such a setup
right
Kaleigh I am willing to give you the
opportunity to take back that dumb
stupid thing that you said so can you
just admit that you're wrong and
incompetent and an idiot and we the
press are right and we're going to
dictate how you do your job I lose lated
but that's what the reporter was getting
at
caitli mcenany keeps her composure and
then responds perfectly well first let
me note I was asked a question on Fox
Business about president's travel
restrictions I noted what was the intent
behind those travel restrictions which
is we will not see the coronavirus come
here
we will not see terrorism come here
referring to an earlier set of travel
restrictions I guess I would turn the
question back on the media and ask
similar questions does Vox want to take
back that they proclaim that the
coronavirus would not be a deadly
pandemic does the Washington Post want
to take back that they told Americans to
get a grip the flu is bigger than the
coronavirus which is the Washington Post
likewise want to take back that our
brains are causing us to exaggerate the
threats of the corona virus does the New
York Times want to take back that fear
of the virus may be expressed spreading
faster than the virus itself does NPR
want to take back that the flu was a
much bigger threat than the corona virus
and finally once again the Washington
Post would they like to take back but
the government should not respond
aggressively to the corona virus I'll
leave you with those questions but maybe
you'll have some answers in a few days
how about you guys answer you report is
actually as she walks out of the room he
can hear one of them say you were
prepared for that like yeah she was
professionals prepare I don't think that
the press were prepared for that
themselves the silver lining I don't
want to leave you without hope you're
the silver lining on all of this with
the press ganging up against you trying
to divide Americans trying to get them
to focus on the shiny object in the
corner rather than the rank corruption
that is before their eyes that they're
implicated in the silver lining is
sometimes the press are their own worst
sometimes the press undercut their own
argument and I saw this on the Today
Show on NBC they were doing a segment on
The Today Show on the Gerber baby right
this is so such a soft fluffy segment
how could this have national political
import NBC News the the whole left-wing
media apparatus right completely gung-ho
behind abortion always talking about
abortion is women's health care women's
rights the war on women if you ever try
to protect little babies so they do a
segment on the Gerber baby no big deal
and you have a family that has this
adopted baby so the new Gerber baby is
this little black girl and the family is
a white family so it's pretty pretty
clear from the outset that the baby is
adopted and I guess NBC just didn't
think about the implications of doing a
story that's all focused on adoption
listen to the way that NBC allows a
wonderful pro-life message to get out on
network television
Courtney you entered magnolias into the
running because your family's story is a
really important one that you wanted to
share can you explain why that is they
chose her life incredible journey today
and if you could hear the joy oh what a
great story if NBC only knew that this
was the way it was gonna go they never
would have aired it right because right
now with the left is trying to do is
push a message of racial division based
on sensationalizing a sad local story
and trying to pretend that this has
implications for the broader politics
that were
some sort of epidemic of racial killing
of white guys racist whites killing
black guys hunting them down on the
street you know basically they're just
hiding their Klan oh it's right and this
is not borne out by the statistics it is
not happening but that's the story
they're trying to do because they want
to keep Americans divided and angry and
focused on things that let them off the
hook and then they accidentally allow
this story through which is a story of
wonderful racial harmony right of
adoption of coming together the story of
the adoptive parents speaking to the
biological parents and having them
involved in a way to say look if you
chose life for your kid and look at what
a great life your kid gets and the kid
is like very cute baby obviously you
know it's being selected as the Gerber
baby and she's there like bop bop bop
bop you know and it's very very
heartwarming
to watch this the news doesn't like to
let too many of those stories get
through particularly when it undercuts
the narratives they're making about
Society and the arguments that they're
making about the value of human life but
every so often often through the media's
own incompetence one of those stories
sneaks through and you begin to see the
truth about the country the truth about
where we are there's some bad actors
trying to Jenna sup and divide us and
work against us and those people are
being exposed not by the media but by
investigators in the DOJ okay and the
the real truth about America though is
beyond them things are okay people
actually get along we do have a love of
our country no matter how much the
ideologue try to rile us up against our
country there is this kind of abiding
love
and it's why unthinkable events like the
election of Donald Trump unthinkable
events alike people coming together
those do happen even despite a press
working all against us stay on guard
don't let them distract you with the
stories that they want you to focus on
with the feelings that they want you to
feel keep your eyes on what is really
going on because there are some
interesting days ahead that's our show
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stevens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
fenders hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen